una elección indudablemente relevante en
medio de muchos bemoles como sabemos el
país está en vilo porque no sabemos qué
va a pasar con los votos que se van a
emitir por medio del correo se ha
hablado de algún tipo de fraude como lo
ha señalado el presidente de donald
trump pero también los demócratas han
mostrado su asombro y no en el sentido
positivo sino que el hecho de que muchos
de estos buzones han sido retirados de
las calles y obviamente estoy encendido
las alarmas porque muchos lo consideran
como una afrenta a la democracia
el seguro vamos a escuchar es a ese
acontecimiento es lo que está ocurriendo
ese desarrollo en el transcurso de esta
semana y veremos vamos a ver de qué de
qué está hecho de qué está hecha está
esta llave demócrata y compuesta por joe
biden y quemada generis'
aunque han avivado por supuesto las las
emociones dentro del partido demócrata y
esto se vio reflejado en él en la
cantidad de dinero que incluso ellos
recogieron en el momento que se anunció
la cámara here it como la compañera de
campaña para joe baile así que vamos a
ver
qué es lo que va a proponer el
presidente y el vicepresidente yo vaya
actualmente con cámara xerez y esto es
lo que analizaremos vamos a ver como los
latinos se han reflejado en lo que ellos
vayan a proponer el tema de la justicia
criminal que es uno de los el talón de
aquiles para que managers y paraguay den
el tema de la economía porque como lo
mencionamos lamentablemente muchas
personas han perdido sus empleos muchos
están esperando una ayuda del gobierno
así que esto lo analizaremos en el
transcurso de esta desde esa primera
noche de una convención que como ya lo
ha mencionado es sui generis